bonjour à toutes et à tous moi je vais
vous inviter à aller au delà de
l'horizon de notre société
avant je suis économiste professeur dans
une petite université du new jersey
qu'on appelle l'université de princeton
est une question qui m'a toujours pas
rôdés
c'est la suivante est ce que les
chercheurs peuvent nous aider à
construire une meilleure société est ce
que moi chercheur je peux faire quelque
chose dans ce sens là les éditorialistes
ne sont pas tendres avec nous nicholas
kristof du new york times a écrit les
quelques années professeur sortez de
votre tour d'ivoire
vraiment il n'ya pas beaucoup de gens
parmi vous qui compte dans le débat
public et plus récemment nicolas truong
a écrit dans le monde qu'en écoutant la
dernière édition de la nuit des idées il
avait l'impression d'assister non
seulement à une pensée du déclin mais
aussi au déclin de la pensée je crois
qu'effectivement on a une responsabilité
de sortir de la tour d'ivoire et
notamment parce que le débat public
n'est pas vraiment à la page les
sciences sociales se sont développées
énormément en particulier depuis la
dernière guerre mondiale et on a
l'impression que beaucoup de choses qui
sont connus dans le milieu académique ne
sont pas vraiment passées dans le milieu
public et puis en plus on est à un
moment historique intéressant les
idéologies totalitaires du 20e siècle
sont peut-être pas tout à fait morte
mais quasi morte et elle ont fait
tellement de dégâts
et maintenant les gens sont beaucoup
plus ouverts à la recherche de solutions
réalistes pragmatiques et surtout
surtout humaniste alors je me suis
lancée il ya quelques années en 2013
dans un colloque à paris
j'ai proposé de retourner sur la
question du futur de la société et j'ai
le proposait de le faire de façon
collective parce que les sciences
sociales se sont tellement développé
qu'il est impossible à un cerveau unique
d'absorber tout ce matériau donc j'ai
proposé de monter un panel international
sur le changement social et contre toute
attente je dois dire que il ya des
collègues qui m'ont pris au sérieux et
par petits groupes par affinités par
connaissance par réseau nous avons fini
par monter ce panel et deux ans plus
tard nous avons fait notre premier
congrès
à istanbul et le panel a décidé de
s'appeler un panel sur le progrès social
ce qui était plus volontariste que
simplement sur le changement le
changement social nous avons essayé de
le composer avec les différentes
disciplines qui sont importantes mais
aussi avec une bonne diversité de genres
est d'origine géographique des
participants
ça a été une aventure humaine assez
extraordinaire mais je ne suis pas venu
ici pour vous parler de moi ou même du
groupe en tant que tel je voudrais vous
parler de nos idées et de ce que nous
aimerions faire passer comme message à
partir de notre travail
donc quelle vision proposons nous pour
nos sociétés
je vais d'abord vous parler de notre
vision des tendances actuelles et puis
après je vous parlerai de comment
imaginer le futur
alors en ce qui concerne les tendances
actuelles
au fond la situation actuelle c'est que
l'humanité est au sommet de ses
possibilités mais fait face à un
précipice au sommet des possibilités
parce que nous avons engrangé des succès
extraordinaire dans de nombreux domaines
mais en même temps il ya des menaces qui
monte à l'horizon et qui s'accumulent et
qui peuvent conduire à des catastrophes
qui risque de tout balayer par exemple
la croissance le pib par tête dans le
monde a été multiplié par quatre depuis
la dernière guerre mondiale ce qui
remarquable
oui mais ça pousse la planète au bord de
ses limites environnementales le
changement climatique la pollution des
eaux notamment et des eaux côtières et
les problèmes de la biodiversité
autre exemple nous avons réussi à
réduire considérablement la pauvreté le
taux de pauvreté dans le monde a été
divisé en quelques décennies par quatre
surtout grâce au développement
économique de la chine
très bien oui mais le légat de
croissance lié notamment à la
globalisation de l'économie ont été
inégalement répartie laissant sur le
côté une partie de la population
notamment les plus pauvres mais aussi
les travailleurs des pays riches qui ont
été choquées par les
par le les blés les chocs commerciaux ou
par la transition technologique et
notamment la l'automatisation
autre exemple du côté des institutions
la démocratie progresse le nombre de
démocraties dans le mans a été multiplié
par quatre là encore je sais pas
pourquoi le chiffre quatre tarifs
magique dans ces histoires c'est très
bien c'est facile à retenir que vous
faites une conférence est parfait et
mais par contre les démocraties en même
temps sont fragilisés par des troubles
liés à la montée du populisme de la
xénophobie et les gens quand on leur
pose la question est ce que vous pensez
qu'il est essentiel de vivre dans une
démocratie on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une
tendance à une décroissance des réponses
à cette question des réponses positives
et notamment ce qui est plus inquiétant
chez les jeunes générations sont ceux
qui ceux qui sont nés le plus récemment
et enfin les gens sont de plus en plus
connectés très bien mais ils vont se
retrouver sur des sites ou sur des
groupes qui véhiculent des rumeurs qui
véhiculent des théories
conspirationnistes et sacs produits une
situation où les gens ont de moins en
moins confiance dans les institutions
le degré de confiance dans les
institutions n'a jamais été aussi bas et
c'est quasiment dans tous les pays il ya
quelques exceptions mais c'est quand
même assez inquiétant et alors tous ces
phénomènes
malheureusement peuvent se renforcer les
un réseau toutes ces menaces peuvent
produire des cercles vicieux et c'est là
que le risque de catastrophes apparaître
quelques exemples quand les inégalités
augmentent dans les pays
ce non c'est non seulement les
inégalités de richesse de revenus mais
aussi la concentration du pouvoir et de
l'influencé qui fait que la politique se
met au service de ses intérêts y compris
pour renforcer les inégalités
voilà un cercle vicieux autre exemple le
changement climatique produit des
troubles environnementaux qui peuvent
mettre le stress sur certaines
populations par exemple au moyen orient
une sécheresse assez longues a été
enregistrée ces dernières années
donc produisant un terreau fertile à des
conflits à du terrorisme produisant une
vague migratoire laquelle produit une
psychose dans les pays riches
contribuent à déstabiliser la politique
à faire élire des démagogues qui veulent
fermer les frontières et qui veulent
aussi se retirer de toute la coopération
internationale y compris l'accord de
paris qui permettait justement de
s'occuper du climat les mêmes démagogues
d'ailleurs se lance dans des nouvelle
course aux armements et se vante d'avoir
des boutons nucléaire plus gros que les
autres
vous le savez peut-être l'année dernière
l'horloge qui mesurent la proximité à
l'hiver nucléaire
cette horloge a été montée à deux
minutes avant minuit ce qui est son
niveau le plus élevé qu'elle n'a jamais
eu depuis sa création
alors je ne raconte pas ça pour vous
effrayer pour vous décourager au
contraire pour compte faire il faut se
mobiliser pour essayer de réagir avant
qu'il soit trop tard et il faut agir sur
trois fronts de bataille en même temps
le premier c'est l'équité il faut
réduire les inégalités entre pays et à
l'intérieur des pays
il faut promouvoir la démocratie et la
liberté qui vont ensemble
contrairement à ce qu'on dit parfois et
il faut s'occuper de l'écologie
préserver l'environnement pour les
générations futures et les trois fronts
il faut les attaquer en même temps c'est
nécessaire de faire des progrès sur les
trois en même temps si on néglige les
quitter on pourrait par exemple se dire
après tout pourquoi ne pas limiter le
développement à la moitié de l'humanité
et préserver la planète grâce au fait
que le reste de l'humanité l'autre
moitié ne se développe pas ce régime
d'apartheid mandanne mondiale en quelque
sorte c'est quelque chose qui ne
fonctionneraient pas parce que d'abord
les gens finir est quand même par se
développer on ne peut pas complètement
les empêcher heureusement mais surtout
ça créerait des conflits des vagues
migratoires
ça n'est pas viable on pourrait imaginer
de laisser de côté l'environnement se
disant au fond accrochons-nous aux
institutions célébré par francis
fukuyama l'économie de marché la
démocratie libérale
faisons confiance à ses bonnes vieilles
recettes éprouvées espérons que le
progrès technologique sauvera la planète
là aussi c'est peu probable
parce que l'environnement demandent des
changements de pratiques plus profond et
donc on n'y arrivera pas si on se
contente des vieilles recettes et enfin
il ya ce que j'appelle la tentation
autoritaire
ça serait tellement simple si on avait
un régime qui permettait de contrôler de
façon ferme la croissance de la
population qui permettait d'imposer un
changement des comportements
ça serait beaucoup plus simple mais vous
le savez l'autoritarisme s'accompagnent
très vite de corruption et
malheureusement les dictateur
bienveillant
c'est très rare sur le marché donc il
faut regarder vers l'avenir et il faut
essayer d'imaginer quelque chose
alors qu'est ce que nous proposons est
bien ne savons pas s'il faut une
révolution ou quelque chose de plus de
plus doux que cela mais en tout cas la
vision que nous proposons qui nous
paraît la plus prometteuse c'est celle
d'une société plus participative et la
participation ce n'est pas seulement une
question de politique c'est aussi
quelque chose qui doit se passer dans
l'économie est d'ailleurs l'économie de
marché qui est notre horizon en termes
d'organisation de l'économie l'économie
de marché c'est une économie au fond
relativement partie participatif puisque
chacun consommateurs producteurs à de
l'autonomie dans ses décisions
mais l'économie de marché d'accord mais
le capitalisme tel que nous le
connaissons ça c'est beaucoup moins
intéressant parce que le capitalisme que
nous connaissons c'est un fonctionnement
qui est mis au service de la valeur pour
l'actionnaire au détriment des autres
parties prenantes
il faut donc que les entreprises se
réforme pour que les intérêts de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes soient
pris en considération dans les objectifs
de l'entreprise et dans la gouvernance
des entreprises
en un mot il faut les démocratiser on
peut aussi essayer de favoriser les
entreprises à mission c'est-à-dire celle
qui ce qui s'en vient non pas seulement
vers la valeur pour l'ensemble des
parties prenantes mais aussi pour des
missions plus large des missions
sociales par exemple ou des missions
environnementales vous avez le mouvement
des bénéfices cooperation aux états unis
qui est une initiative très intéressante
et qui prend de l'ampleur maintenant
dans pas mal de pays
et puis il faut aussi s'occuper de la
concurrence c'est à dire
attaquer la concentration des intérêts
financiers qui a été considérable dans
les dernières années
si vous regardez les centres entités
économiques les plus importantes dans le
monde
vous trouvez 40 états et 60 entreprises
et donc il faut s'attaquer à toutes ces
rentes de situation qui se sont
développées par exemple en les taxant ou
en régulant et en particulier en matière
de rentes de situation il ya la finance
qui est devenu hypertrophié il faut la
remettre au service de l'économie au
service du financement de l'économie
réelle alors l'état peut avoir un
nouveau rôle dans cette perspective
parce que cette économie plus
participatif plus démocratique
elle ne fonctionnera pas bien si l'état
ne la soutient pas si l'état ne garantit
pas les nouveaux droits démocratiques
dans l'ensemble des organisations
économiques
donc c'est un rôle pour l'état qui est
plus ambitieux que simplement la voiture
balai qui s'occupe de ceux qui ont été
rejetés par le système de ceux qui ont
échoué
un état qui promeut l'émancipation de
chacun la participation à ces nouveaux
droits
bien sûr il ya encore des éléments plus
classique qu'il faut garder par exemple
des services universels des services qui
permettent d'assurer plus d'égalité des
chances parce que chacun a accès à des
choses de qualité par exemple dans le
domaine de l'éducation ou de la santé
il faut expérimenter avec un revenu
minimum garanti pourquoi cette formule
est intéressante parce qu'elle donne une
sécurité réelle à chacun qui permet
d'être plus ferme quand on doit négocier
avec d'autres mais aussi de prendre plus
de risques si on veut si on veut en
prendre
et puis il faut s'occuper de l'héritage
il faut lutter contre la formation des
dynasties financière des dynasties de
fortune pas forcément en taxant
l'héritage mais en imposant en
encourageant en incitant à redistribuer
véritable si vous vous enrichissez
pourquoi pas si vous voulez le garder
dans votre famille est construit une
dynastie
c'est très mauvais parce que vous tuez
l'égalité des chances et donc il faut
redistribuer largement
et puis enfin l'état a un rôle à jouer
dans la transition écologique non
seulement en encourageant
l'investissement la recherche et
développement mais aussi
en utilisant éventuellement cette
transition pour avoir des nouvelles
sources de revenus par exemple la taxe
carbone peut servir pendant la
transition à financer les
infrastructures dont on a besoin ou des
politiques sociales qui permettent aux
gens de conserver un accès à l'énergie
et enfin il faut revenir aussi à la
politique
j'ai parlé de l'augmentation du nombre
de démocraties dans le monde très bien
en termes de quantité mais en terme de
qualité qu'en est il si la confiance des
gens dans les institutions décline c'est
que la qualité n'est pas brillante
brillant par exemple le rôle de l'argent
dans la politique
le sénateur john mccain qui n'était pas
exactement un gauchiste disait il ya
quelques années la politique aux états
unis ça consiste à vendre les postes
électifs au plus offrant tout le
problème des financements de campagnes
électorales de l'activité des partis
alliés à 7 à cette question il faut
organiser un financement plus
transparent pas forcément uniquement
public peut-être plutôt un financement
qui inclut une bonne dose de
participation et puis il ya le problème
des médias et des médias sociaux
on s'inquiète beaucoup maintenant des
manipulations qui ont lieu au moment des
élections
mais les médias classiques sont aussi
une source de problèmes par la
concentration financière qui s'est
opérée dans leurs dernières années dans
pas mal de pays et qui donne un poids
dans la formation de l'opinion publique
qui est excessif à certains grands
propriétaires de médias et donc il faut
traiter les médias comme des biens
communs et organiser leur gestion le
contrôle de leur gouvernance et même de
leur contenu de la qualité de leur
contenu d'une façon qui engage la
société civile et puis dans la politique
il n'ya pas seulement les élections il
faut organiser aussi de la participation
plus régulière pour que des citoyens par
exemple tiré au sort puissent s'informer
sur certaines questions et dans des mini
public émettre des avis sur des
décisions qui sont à prendre au moment
présent
et puis finalement les règles de vote
qu'on a sont encore aujourd'hui trop
souvent des règles de vote qu'ils sont
vulnérable à la présence de petits
candidats qui sont non pertinent parce
qu'ils ne seront jamais élus mais qui
changent le l'ordre des candidats
principaux
il existe des règles de vote qui sont
beaucoup plus robuste et qui sont aussi
plus attentifs plus film qui permettent
à l'électeur de formuler ses préférences
ses jugements de façon plus plus
plus intéressant alors ses chances cette
vision d'une société plus participative
est ce que c'est un château en espagne
comme on dit en france une tarte dans le
ciel comme disent les anglais ou les
américains en fait pour que ce soit
quelque chose qui soit qui viennent
qu'ils soient réalisés
il faut qu'un mouvement partent de la
base ça ne viendra pas du ciel justement
et chacun peut y contribuer et chacun
peut y contribuer d'autant plus que les
ingrédients de cette société
participatique sont au fond déjà parmi
nous même les entreprises démocratique
ça existe il ya des nouveaux
entrepreneurs qui organise les choses de
façon horizontale c'est remarquable avec
une dimension d'épanouissement humain
tout à fait extraordinaire dans l'or
dans leurs entreprises
donc il y à il ya plein de choses qui se
passent les politiques étatiques dont
j'ai parlé elle existe déjà dans pas mal
de pays et il faut simplement les
développer et chacun en fait là où il
est peut créer des espaces de justice
autour de soi pour que ces espaces et
valeur d'exemple et contribue à former
ce mouvement ce mouvement qui pousse
vers cette société et donc quelques
exemples de choses que l'on peut faire
chacun dans sa vie la famille par
exemple vraiment l'endroit où les gens
se forment se construisent pour aller
vers le monde
la famille peut être un lieu de justice
si on donne une égale dignité à chacun
si on respecte les différences
j'ai parlé beaucoup du travail oui il
faut promouvoir la participation si on
crée une entreprise on peut le faire si
on est un simple salarié c'est un peu
plus difficile mais on peut quand même
poussé dans cette direction
au pire on peut toujours voté avec ses
pieds et essayer d'aller trouver des
entreprises - moins corrompus et puis
les consommateurs les épargnants peuvent
voter avec leurs dollars et pousser
l'économie dans une direction plus
éthique et aussi poussé à ce qu'il y ait
plus d'informations sur les produits que
ce que l'on donne habituellement sur les
étiquettes et la vie des quartiers la
vie des villages c'est quelque chose que
chacun peut contribuer à améliorer on
n'a jamais été aussi connecté mais il ya
une épidémie de solitude dans pas mal de
pays développés donc il faut s'y
attaquer et contribuer à revivifier le
tissu social je parlais des médias
maintenant le simple fait d'être
un informé de choisir ses sources
d'informations de façon consciente
ça devient un acte militant et donc il
faut il faut le faire il faut bloquer la
le partage la dissémination des rues
main et puis il ne faut pas oublier la
politique parce que ce mouvement de la
base qui va créer des nouvelles
pratiques
à un moment donné il faudra que les
nouvelles pratiques deviennent de
nouvelles normes que la loi formaliste
tout cela pour que ça passe à l'échelle
supérieure que ça devienne quelque chose
dont tout le monde puisse profiter et
donc être un citoyen actif ça fait
partie des choses que chacun peut faire
voilà je vous invite à venir rejoindre
notre conversation vous pouvez aller
regarder notre site internet ip sp point
org
lire notre petit manifeste pour le
progrès social qui est paru en anglais
et en français et dans quelques autres
langues
lire notre gros apport en trois volumes
de kilos et demi plein de références
plein d'études sur l'ensemble des
questions sociales et puis il ya un
documentaire qui a été fait par réalisé
par sophie walter et qui décrit à la
fois notre aventure et qui explore avec
quelques membres de notre groupe
la façon dont on peut imaginer une
nouvelle société
ce film est trouvable sur internet voilà
je vois que c'est beaucoup
[Applaudissements]